you guys remember drake bell of course
he was on the nickelodeon show drake and
josh
oh okay well he's an uh nickelodeon
actor he was really big
as a like what what
who no no no i've never heard him
like teen actor in the early 2000's he
tried to transition
out into a music career oh he's all
thick
no he is the skinny one josh peck was
the
thick one yeah but he recently uh
went on to social media and changed all
of his social media handles
to the name drake compania
and he is now doing spanish music he
moved to mexico
and he's doing like this whole rebrand
he only types on social media in spanish
he does only spanish music and he's kind
of like claiming mexico now
i love it wow find yourself can you do
that you got to do something i mean
it says he might be rebranding because
that accused of sexual
what uh so last year his ex-girlfriend
from like 10 years ago came out on tick
tock and said that
he abused her when they were in a
relationship he came out and said
it wasn't true and that she asked him
for money apparently
it's like verbally and physically
abusive they don't really go into too
much
some fans speculate that bell's rebrand
could be tied as denial of
abuse allegations made by his
ex-girlfriend august
fairly recent but yeah but apparently
the abuse happened 10 years ago like
they haven't dated
any time recently and she wants money
you said yeah he came out and
when the accusations were posted onto
tick tock he said that
she actually hit him up like a month
before asking for financial help and he
helped her and now
that happened it's kind of like a big he
said she said
but yeah drake bell is mexican now
apparently do we have any of his mexican
music yeah
on his instagram i don't know i think
you can find it on youtube drake
i want to campana his instagram i bet
the [ __ ] show yeah shout out to drake
and josh because that birthed eye carly
that was your
that was your [ __ ] that was a spin-off
that was expensive because miranda uh
about real mexican by the way miranda
she
that's 4.5 million followers
go to that middle one chin yeah he's
about to sing right there okay let's
hear it oh damn look all spanish
where is this in mexico that is a white
boy
there's no way just post this [ __ ]
it's almost a minute right
yeah it might be like the intro to his
music video
yeah it's all sad hello
[Laughter]
he's not playing the guitar oh there you
go it'd be funny if all his
what is he talking about right here in
the top left apologizing for whatever
hey drake bell here just letting you
know i'm available on cameo for any type
of special messages
he went right he went back to caucasian
how long were you pretend
that when somebody jumps on cameo
they're doing good in life
how long are we gonna pretend
if you're on camera you ain't doing it
because you got a lot of options
they came at your boy i said get the
[ __ ] out of here
they came they came at you all the time
still all the time
yo hey couple your friends are on here i
don't give anything
hey come on your friends huh just think
about it
ryan was on there for two dollars
singing happy birthday every [ __ ]
sunday
stop it you were coming to the studio
doing cameos
oh you would yeah it's funny you see us
in the back
he's like you're singing happy birthday
to fans yeah brian yeah someone's like
hey can you sing happy birthday that you
know
i'm like happy birthday dave you know
like
what would you do what would you do
nothing i want nothing i don't want any
part of it
i talk too much for a living i don't
need another outlet
dog i get i got a cleaner you don't have
a cleaner he's been saying that forever
hey we're not gonna burn those
no we gotta we gotta might need to give
them to drake um
we hang those like we can hang these up
those could be like uh
trophy yeah it was trophy we can't burn
these
trophies i just want to hear this
dumbass sing yeah
seriously he wasn't even speaking
spanish when he was promoting i don't
know
this dude how spanish is this a white
dude trying to figure you know
i don't think he's spanish or mexican
you know lost you got to be to
switch your whole vibe up and start
singing spanish what if his music is
dope though
is let's better worse than vince paul
let's pause it better
better than vin diesel let's go around
the room go oh wait real quick this
could be the other reason why he's
doing this shenanigans you know lap
music was the most
streamed genre of music out of any other
music genre in the world
lap music so like balvin
bad bunny uh my favorite uh
well i love uh maluma and then uh carol
carroll g do you know what carol g yeah
great mm-hmm
yes okay yeah i know um
g is like she's khloe kardashian if she
had talent
she looks identical to her yeah
she's such a baddie recently single
broke up with uh
yeah who's awesome
they're best friends he's argentinian
that's your favorite song you said by uh
six nine of him yeah dude the women in
that video
what i didn't even see it yeah they she
bro yeah that's the girl right yeah
that's him
i love carrick daniel annual annual
you said she's single now yep they broke
up she's bad she watches oh she's so
bad i don't know she just shot sure she
does look like chloe
yeah she's uh she's chloe if chloe had
talent continuing
okay let's see dumb ass real quick
wait hold on give a tech is better than
vin diesel um i doubt it's better than
you
who else had a song vin diesel who else
had a song that we were listening to
i think it was just ben diesel is it
just him but he had like changed
chat hanks oh oh yeah hey do i also
celebrate
go check all right let's go all right so
number one okay i bet vin diesel is just
it's way more produced so it sounds
better probably but this guy's
who knows what this guy is maybe he's
writing his own [ __ ] okay he might be
what'd you say
this [ __ ] probably trash oh yeah i'm
with you all right
so he's speaking
so mostly english but not a great singer
right chin yeah
i mean i can't tell it's it's like it's
hard it's hard that's awesome
right there chimera's playing the
[ __ ] guitar
pissed off so hard on this guy right now
he's not bad with the guitar aren't you
oneness i mean he's playing but there's
also a track playing
okay so he's not bad at all okay he's
not bad he's actually a pretty good
guitar
oh carefully drop that n word buddy
he can't just be a white boy he was like
you know what let me try getting on this
latin craze right now
yeah some background shout out to the
spanish people maybe
is
hey how about it says his ethnic
background is mostly white
he has not been vocal about having
latino heritage at all
oh that's hilarious portuguese
english scottish and swedish a white boy
from newport
all right i love that someone on google
was like we don't claim him
basically someone said that caucasian it
just says caucasian
as [ __ ] nice nice try drake how about
that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son